freunde herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video ich bin die heute in der
küche von joule denn ich werde den
ganzen tag für zu kochen ist ein sehr
persönlicher kopf und wir starten heute
mit einem klassiker und zwar mit dem
englisch braig für sehr entspannt für
mich weil jetzt nicht auch wenn ich
zuzubereiten ist aber kannst du sagen
verstehen weil das knallt einfach so da
das ist einfach durch so ein festmahl
das bereiten jetzt du dich zeigt sich
erst mal was wir brauchen
ich habe fast alles was zu einem
traditionellen im gespräch ist gehört
champignons jake and sources drahtbürste
tomaten baked beans und eier
man würde eigentlich noch pudding also
blutwurst dazu machen da war ich mir
nicht so sicher ob das jeder markt
ansonsten haben wir glaube ich alles am
start bzw
klar ist könnten andere bratwurst zu
sein aber wir sind ganz gut unterwegs
und wir können eigentlich ohne weitere
vorbereitungen direkt anfangen und
unseren herd anschmeißen ich glaube dass
hier ist eine nachricht von muri also
nur zwei platten gleichzeitig benutzen
nicht drei hat uns anscheinend der strom
ausgeht könnte kleinen challenge werden
aber wird schon funktionieren also wie
gesagt wir schmeißen erstmal den heran
bratwürste mache ich glaube ich in
diesem drehte hier
hier oben lasse ich die fahne auch schon
mal langsam heiß werden ich habe meine
recherche auch gehört dass so ein
english breakfast 1000 kalorien hat ist
also auf jeden fall leichter sprache den
tag so ich fange direkt an unsere
tomaten
das wetter war schon weichen für die
wasch ich kurz und dann wollen wir den
stromkreis die einzige weitere sache die
wir schneiden müssen sonst ist quasi
wirklich alles schon fertig ist
toastbrot und zwar teile mir das einfach
in so klassische sandwich dritte so das
war's mitschneiden fertig so ich gebe es
mal die bratwürste hier in die pfanne
wir brauchen wir gesagt am nächsten ist
aufgeben wir sie als erstes land nutzen
dafür so eine grillpfanne dann kriegen
sie auch noch so ein schönes muster
darauf parallel strebe schon mal den
backofen heißt es gibt bestimmt ein paar
sachen gewann halten müssen gerade wenn
wir nur zwei herdplatten benutzen kann
es leider wirklich nicht super viel
platz mit dem ich arbeiten kann
aber ich werde hier wegen der größe
anpassen dann rüber
so wecken und bratwürste sind schon am
antraten
so ich geh jetzt hier zu den bratwürsten
in die pfanne unsere tomaten die tomaten
kosten der sozial sind von einer seite
ein bisschen an
wir wollen aber nicht dass die super
weich werden also es geht darum ja so
ein bisschen resta romance direkt weiter
war so ein bisschen geschmack noch ein
zu bekommen unser tag und wird langsam
christi das wollen wir gar nicht
unbedingt als ich gesehen habe muss
erhitze runter komme ich nun auch die
andere seite beziehungsweise nicht
ziehen jetzt schon raus
mehr soll es einfach nicht sein können
irgendwie strecken sitzen abtropfen
lassen und dann können wir hier in die
pfanne direkt soll auch schön so wurzeln
unserer sandwich eingeben so die tomaten
kommen aufbaus kommen auch in den
gruppen zum warmhalten indem wir ein
bisschen butter an die stelle wo die
tomaten waren deutschland kommen dann
einfach ein paar ganze champignons
angetastet damit auch bahn gehalten und
mir kann auch alles und dann gebe ich
jetzt einfach unsere kommt hier oben
anfangen und wir können unsere
einschlagen wollen die schönen christi
haben
hallo ich habe mein video herzlich
willkommen
außerdem hat sich schon mal gelohnt dass
ich hier bin oder ich wollte nicht nur
die ersten zeugen aber braucht also wir
haben hier tomaten ich habe ich alles
von einem klassischen im gespräch frist
aus bluetooth ich war mir nicht sicher
ob das lied der leute sie nicht vorliegt
ich bin auch ein bisschen angst muss ich
sagen weil irgendwie ist hier waren
geworden aber wir müssen jetzt einfach
essen wenn ihr doch so benimmt sie
vereinbart wie oft hast du nimmst eine
gabel und dann geht die kamera aus und
dann ist er ganz in ruhe und dann erst
wieder andere bewertete die nicht wer
das ist doch so ein geiles frühstück
oder über das war immer so einen traum
irgendwann im kopf zu haben was liebst
du am im gespräch für euch liebe ja
boden gut dass zwei dosen gemacht habe
ich kein trinkwasser für diese fans oder
ja wirklich so dass ich habe auch dieses
essen überhaupt erst kennengelernt in
hotels ganz wichtig für mich zumindest
versuchen frühstück shop.de es natürlich
das ganze ist jetzt in klassischen sauce
dazu aber nicht bekommen welche
webseiten nicht nur also dann lasst euch
schmecken
gut fertig geworden lange strecke via
steam eine kleine portionen fertig
gemacht erst später so dass unser herz
ihr geschmeckt sagt beat sich geil war
so flashbacks immer eine zeit wo die
hotels gelebt habe sagte er ich liebe
einfach in die bläck fööss die busfahrer
geld und das brot alters hat alles
getoppt
wer jetzt effekt auf streckt auch
perfekt eigentlich esse ich morgens
nichts weil ich hier war die mieterin
das fasten mache pc heute ich hab schon
immer wieder gesagt es kommt
wahrscheinlich 1000 kalorien wird
zuhause kalorie hatte das jetzt
vielleicht der code ist mit du hast ist
sie gewöhnt dass die würden stärkt jetzt
wird schwer jetzt musst du das ganze in
einer note packen muss dazu sagen würde
du hat sich saft von mir gewünschten
frischen orangensaft sonntag in
vergessen krise ein minuspunkt dann auf
jeden fall 19
hey das ist doch ein guter start in den
tag sagt euch ehrlich das mittagessen
das anders das wird anders ist so sterne
mäßig und wenn sie müssen mittagessen
ghailani so lebe ich gerne so volle
weiter geht es mit dem mittagessen und
ich hab da was ganz besonderes vor uns
war hat kevin romys letztes für mich
lachs in der spülmaschine gemacht was
erstmal komisch klingt es war einfach
nur so für entertainment und der
zubereitung
er hat das ganze aber mit grünem spargel
gegrillt und polenta gemacht und ich
habe das gegessen und ich dachte wir so
weit haben das muss ich für jemanden
kochen ist alles juli als der glückliche
der das von gekocht bekommt wir fahren
direkt an ich bereite den lachs nicht in
der spülmaschine sondern sowie zu ich
habe hier viel lachsfilets weil das team
auch mit ist was ein bisschen größere
portionen ergeben hier einfach so schön
unser lachsfilet in den makro mir beute
und dazu ein bisschen butter das würde
ich auch thymian oder sonstige kräuter
will sich gut drin machen ich habe sie
einfach vergessen
somit habe ich euch da glaube ich schon
mal erklärt in einem video man packt das
ganze einfach in diesem beute in ein
wasserbad dass überall die gleiche
temperatur hatten und so zieht der fisch
auf die perfekte kerntemperatur und das
einzige was man dann am 1
noch machen möchte um zu verpassen indem
man ihn in die pfanne haut wenn dann
alle fälle ist eingeschweißte starten
wir uns hier unseren speed starb man
braucht es wirklich nicht man kann es
auch wird eine spülmaschine mache und
guckt euch die gesagt dass die per video
an
hier stellt hier die temperatur auf 50
grad
und so geben wir das ganze jetzt einfach
in den tag hinein ins wasserbad mit
jetzt auf 54 grad erhitzt dadurch kriegt
der fisch auf 54 grad und steht schon
die fahne für den spargel bereit aber
wir setzen als erstes die polenta auf
und sage ich jetzt 500 milliliter schlag
rahmen und 500 milliliter ist
folgerichtig mal direkt mal ein bisschen
salz und pfeffer rein
man könnte jetzt auch schon frische
muskeln zusammen hatten aber alex
austrias team ist allergisch deshalb
mache ich das zum schluss erst rein
wir bereiten aber auch direkt man so
einen grünen spargel vor das wird keine
riesen mahlzeit jetzt wir sind auch
glaube ich alle noch sehr gut gesättigt
von dem english breakfast wir nehmen für
jeden einfach drei vier stangen spargel
dann passt das ganze auf jeden fall bei
unseren spargel schneiden wir ohnehin 23
cm ab ich habe jetzt gerade auch das
licht entdeckt während ihr die milch und
den schlagrahm aufkocht auf jeden fall
immer umrühren damit das ganze nicht
anbrennt so die milch ist jetzt ein mal
aufgekocht das heißt wir geben jetzt 100
gramm polenta dazu und ich gebe die 100
gramm rhein ist es wirklich nicht viel
denkt man zumindest 100 gramm auf einen
liter aber wir werden gleich sehen ja
die gesamte polenta absorbiert die
flüssigkeiten dann hat man wie so ein ja
wieso einen herzhaften grießpudding
eigentlich nur mit mais wenn es manchmal
so auftaucht dann gehen wir auch
wirklich ganz munter auch eine niedrige
hitze so über unseren spargel geben wir
ein wenig öl aber nur damit wir werden
besser angreifen können
das ganze ein bisschen durch und dann
salzen und pfeffern wir einmal wie ihr
sehen könnt ist die polenta schon gut
angelegt ist für uns ist es zeit jetzt
mal nen ordentlichen stich butter daran
zu geben
die bratpfanne ist schon heiß geworden
und wir geben den spargel rein ich
erinnere mich gerade dass kevin das
gestern mit einem schneebesen gemacht
hat dementsprechend hätte ich es
wahrscheinlich auch tun sollen hat auch
sogar das kleine klümpchen drin aber ich
glaube dass das überhaupt kein problem
rund um den spargel rausgehen aber in
die pfanne direkt schön hitzebeständige
theaterspiel unschuldig aus den beuteln
und dann wirklich hin zum anvisierten 1
und jetzt richten wir das ganze nur noch
hübsch an und hoffen es mit ein bisschen
zitrone
also das ist ein bisschen stickig hier
unten ordentlich gegrillt wurde und
gebraten wurde in der pfanne
ich hoffe schmeckt es ist eine polenta
mit gegrilltem spargel und lachs poletto
wirklich schmecken wie geil ein sehr
sommerlich testen
[Musik]
das war lecker bin ich fertig geworden
kann ist rosberg ans essen vielleicht
kabarett schon sucht das gespräch das
halt einfach die klappe halten
superlecker kombination sagt es hier die
polonaise hier das könnt ihr euch hier
beim wunsch feier crash proteinreiche
lustig ich bin halt laktose intoleranz
habe ich nicht gesagt habe ich sage da
ist viel drin auf das ist so dass zu des
standards asiatisch geprägten menschen
dass die halle natur sei integration
mega mega mega lecker
das war wirklich der zehn von zehn
wirklich nur 10 von 10
also ich habe so etwas noch nie gegessen
weil ich erst ganz leicht so einfach
nicht echt mega mega ich habe das
gestern auf dem erst mal gegessen so
genau was ich heute bin ich machen
wollte deshalb mache ich mir schon
sicher das system schon google fällt
aber als ich habe ich eine halbe stunde
gekauft dass name und sonst halt dem
bistum haben wir auch schon mal ein
essen heute ist der tag vorher und ich
habe hier ungefähr ein kilo
hähnchenfleisch stärke sei backpulver
ich mache die vorbereitung für unsere
chicken wings rezept euch schon super
lange machen und heute ist es endlich
soweit
ich habe mir einfach ganz gekauft die
härchen flügel man führt dann hier so
weich ist und dort entlang setzen wir
dann in katar dann schneiden wir von der
gegenseite ebenfalls tun
so treffen wir dann nicht lügen
zweiteiler und weiß nicht genau wie
heißt ich hab irgendwie gramm
keine ahnung das geht mir dann hier
rüber das machen wir den ganzen hang
kübeln ich jetzt hier drüben habe und
dann kommen wir zu den vorbereitungen
wir lassen die chicken wings über nacht
im kühlschrank sitzen das ist jetzt ein
ziel und wir geben zwei teelöffel salz
zwei teelöffel speisestärke und zwei
teelöffel backpulver dran und so werden
wir das ganze jetzt durch bis das
gesamte pulver aufgenommen ist von den
flügeln
so sollte das aussehen jetzt schlagen
wir uns einen ort und breiten die flügel
darauf aus soja raps gesehen ich habe
gestern abend eigentlich nur diese super
einfachen schritt gemacht wir gucken uns
mal an wie übrigens jetzt aussehen hier
sieht man es relativ gut also die haut
ist oben recht trocken das haben sie
auch zu kleine bläschen gebildet auf der
haut und ich glaube damit liegen wir
super crunchy chicken wings sind dazu
gibt es ganz klassisch sellerie also
einfach nur so sellerie sticks range
pressing und die broadway shows heißen
ich möchte ein bisschen von dieser
franks red hot socks mit butter und
knoblauch das ist alles die habe ich
vier knoblauchzehen die habe ich von mir
geklaut der mann für alles relativ viel
zeit weil die webseite berufen schon
noch eine weile brauchen
dazu schneidet einfach noch ein bisschen
sellerie klein und es ist auch endlich
der backofen vorgeheizt sie legen das
war erstmal für 20 minuten
[Musik]
so leute es ist soweit war auch dieses
raums allein ist jetzt hier unten ist
super viel von dem öl rausgekommen ich
werde das ganze jetzt mal vorsichtig
wenden damit wir die andere seite auch
so schon crispy bekommen und jetzt kommt
das ganze etwa 20 weitere minuten in den
ofen
sollte hier in unserem top machen wir 30
gramm butter hinein dazu pressen wir
unseren knoblauch gelassen knoblauch
aber nicht braun werden sondern es geht
darum ihn so ein bisschen zu dünsten
damit damit er halt nicht mehr so scharf
ist so der knoblauch ist schon am ball
das heißt wir geben jetzt drei esslöffel
von unserer franks rathaus jetzt ein
wirklich dass man leute man hört einfach
nur mich krank muss man sich das ganze
ist so geben wir es jetzt einfach in
unsere schüssel hinein aber wir geben
was jetzt hier drüber und schrecken
einmal so ist es ist soweit ich wollte
das so lange schon machen
wirklich ich bin sehr hat die mission
gold und braun geworden und zu ist
natürlich jetzt das wichtigste wie dir
das ganze schmecken würden sehr
knoblauch ich ja maximal ich sehr gerne
heute habe ich ausnahmsweise mal kein
date deswegen passt das eigentlich auch
ganz gut was hast du immer na ja das
habe ich jeden tag ein date sehr
anstrengend denn da muss gefüllt werden
können
so heißt aber geil vier dieser palisade
oder was da drauf ist
hast die wahl ist es garantiert keine
pannen das mega gerecht wir sparen uns
ein bisschen was davon für nach dem
stream auch egal im stream sind
ziel von 10 wieder sagen wie viele leute
magazin von 10 ist es gibt schon einige
die sagen aber sie hätten zugestimmt wie
heute war heute auch so happy mit einem
sondern lieber gegessen sehr gefragt
habe jeden tag da wärst alter gesehen
und ich sehe anders aus ich sehe das ja
ich krank das muss jeder nachmachen dann
könne sie zugesehen haben uns bei der
nächsten woche ein tag ist sehr kreativ